it's not Xi Jinping who's sending our
communities Up in Smoke right now you go
to an American city
San Francisco especially good grief you
can barely walk into that City Chicago
D.C Los Angeles New York crime is
spiking disorder is spreading
to the point now where people will just
regularly go into drug stores going to
convenience stores and they'll just go
in they'll have a bag or sometimes
they'll even have one of those gigantic
like 60 gallon trash bins they'll drag
them in and they'll start emptying the
shelves put them in and because our our
justice system has been so perverted and
corrupted
the shop owners are not really allowed
to do anything about it they just have
to call the police the police don't come
it's too much crime and the people just
get away with it and as a result of this
people can't walk down the street in
safety and the shops have to close up
shop
well there's a video just went viral of
some Thug some just ordinary Street Thug
walks in with a giant trash bin into a
convenience store and he just starts
emptying out the cigarettes you know so
it's it's just like in uh Les Miserables
trying to steal a loaf of bread to feed
your family no I don't know I don't
think this guy needs 200 packs of
cigarettes to you know survive until
another day well the shop owners
initially say
you can't do anything
but then no there we go
then
what looks like an immigrant comes over
is one of the guys holds holds the
robber down this this immigrant comes
over and destroys beating him with a
stick
it's a broom handle or something
[Music]
this might be the perfect beat down I've
ever seen and it's the perfect Beatdown
I've ever seen because the guy didn't
shoot him didn't kill him didn't stab
him he's not bleeding out or anything
and even the guy holding the stick he's
just not cracking the guy in the head
he's not giving him a concussion or
brain damage he's just he's just caning
him on his legs and on his torso nothing
is going to leave a really lasting
injury here but it is going to leave him
a lasting lesson I hope and why is this
video so shocking
these kind of robberies go on in cities
all over the country all the time why is
this one so shocking because our
political establishment says hey if you
if you rob a shop you're gonna be let
off the hook you probably won't even get
a slap on the wrist if you loot during
the George Floyd riots for months Coast
to Coast yeah you'll just get your
charges dismissed but if you ever try to
stop a robber we're going to throw the
book at you we're going to charge you
with murder we're gonna send you to
prison for the rest of your life and so
people rightly who understand the way
that our two-tier justice system works
they say look I don't want any part of
that steal my stuff steal my cigarettes
shut down my shop I don't want to go to
prison because of this two-tiered
perverted justice system but then you
see this guy with the turbine the
turbine is the indication to me that
this fella this shop worker is an
immigrant in New York this guy I don't
think he's totally familiar
with
liberal decadent American culture the
culture that says robbers can do
whatever they want but Property Owners
can't so this guy looks at me says hold
on
get over here
and the guy filming he says no man you
can't do anything we got to wait for the
cops to come you're not allowed no you
don't understand man you can't and the
guy with the turban he says uh no I
don't think so hold that guy and then so
the other the other person holds the guy
down you start beating him with a stick
immigrants have much to teach us right
now text Knowles to 98 98 98 we are days
away from the Durbin Accords the
greatest threat to you the US Dollar's
Global dominance in the past 80 years on
August 22nd brics Nations Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa are
expected to announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S and the dollar as
cornerstones of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is right now when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating With Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers text Knowles Canada wlas to 98
98.98 get your free info kit on gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a reality it will be nice to have some
gold to depend upon text Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s to 98 98
98 you know the liberal service we have
so much to learn from the immigrants
well I finally agree
you're right
because in whatever country this guy's
from I prom I don't know what the
country is I don't know when he came
here
I promise you whatever country that guy
is from
they don't just let robbers come in and
take your cigarettes
there is
there is a natural impulse for justice
and if the cops aren't going to provide
it and if the prosecutors aren't going
to provide it and if the political
establishment's not going to provide it
then we're going to have to provide it
ourselves
that's what that guy that's the idea
that that guy is expressing by by
beating the robber very politely very uh
considerately I think with the stick
we have to do it we live in a political
order right now
that forgot about Justice and so the
issue runs a lot deeper than just
letting some criminals go in and steal
your your packs of cigarettes
political order that says there is no
such thing as Justice there's no such
thing as right and wrong beyond what we
say it is a political order that says
that marriage isn't really what marriage
is political order that says
that men are not really men and women
are not really women a political order
that says that up is down and black is
white and
that perversion of Justice
is going to spread everywhere this is
why in New York under Giuliani probably
the best mayor in the history of the
city
New York they pursued
broken windows policing
broken windows policing said we're not
only going to go after the toughest not
only are we not going to let the
criminals off the hook
we're not only going to focus on the
most egregious crimes
we're going to focus on the most minor
crimes we're going to focus on a broken
window because when there's a broken
window in your neighborhood
that's going to attract criminals like
moths to a flame they're going to say oh
there's disorder here okay we can wreak
havoc you've gotta you've got to focus
on that this is why Giuliani went in he
didn't client clean up the nice
neighborhoods he cleaned up Times Square
which was a degenerate neighborhood he
turned Times Square into Disneyland and
he did it to send a message this
city is going to focus on Justice
and once again we were talking about
this with Justin Trudeau when disorder
seeps in it's like rayon in the air
you know it just it just
is it rayon or radon one of them is made
to make cheap T-shirts one of them is a
gas that poisons your family whichever
one it is it's in the air it poisons you
without you even recognizing it okay and
much like that
when one insists upon a principle of
Justice that's going to spread
throughout the year too and people are
going to behave a lot better it's it's
politics is not rocket science it's not
theoretical physics okay if you just
encourage good things and discourage bad
things you're going to get a better
Society boy what a great clip that was
now make sure that you subscribe to the
Michael Knowles Show YouTube channel see
you next time